the series is set in the year 2418 where
the world is transformed into an
ultra-futuristic place humans are now
able to visit other planets through
space travel and the entire galaxy is
explorable in the galaxy there are low
gravity planets like earth and high
gravity planets like zelion in order for
humans to travel to high gravity planets
they need to use protective suits zelion
has 10 times stronger gravity than earth
and even a spaceship needs to activate a
gravity shield to protect the humans
moving out of this shield will make them
instantly fall to the ground as their
weight becomes 10 times heavier even a
material from earth thrown to this
planet will instantly get flattened and
crushed moreover if a person's
protective suit is damaged their body
parts will be destroyed however the
species born on a high gravity planet
possess high density bones and muscles
which makes them stronger than the
species from other planets due to the
comparatively high gravity of their home
planet the zelions are known as one of
the strongest beings in the universe one
such powerful zeleon is alara kitan she
can knock down doors and walls and crush
a solid block of titanium or reshape it
into a sphere with her bare hands she is
a security member of an exploratory
spaceship known as the uss orville the
orville is tasked to maintain order
across the planet and also repel any
dangers from other galaxies if needed
the orville is operated by several other
personnel most of them are humans and
some are aliens its leader captain
mercer is a human who is known for
getting things done one way or another
he's also known for inventing family guy
the series then shows a planet named
sargasso iv where two people are being
interviewed it appears as if they have
committed some sort of crime and the
interviewer keeps asking them if they
are sorry everyone is wearing a strange
badge and it has an upvote and down vote
option on it soon after the public
begins voting if the two criminals
should be published and the live vote
count is displayed on tv i guess reddit
made it to the future later the
criminals are brought to the punishment
room but when one of them tries running
away the cops shoot him down following
this the second criminal is sat on a
chair and a device is placed on his head
as soon as the downvotes reach 10
million he is electrocuted and the scene
changes a few days later the orville
approaches sargassu iv in order to look
for two of their missing researchers the
strange thing about the planet is that
its culture is almost identical to that
of 21st century earth before initiating
the mission captain mercer reveals to
his group that the two researchers had
been sent to sargass4 to study the place
but one month ago they lost all contact
with them he then assigns a team of four
commander kelly dr claire lieutenant
lamar and lieutenant alara to head down
to sargassu iv since alara is different
and has unusual patterns on her face she
wears a traditional sargass hat and
covers her nose with a band-aid before
leaving when the four arrive on the
planet they notice that it is awfully
similar to 21st century earth strangely
the people use their badges as if it is
a daily part of their life for instance
a man compliments his friend's weight
loss so he is given an upvote and
another man accidentally spills his
coffee onto a stranger prompting him to
get a down vote in short the sargass4 is
a completely democratic country where
the general population decides
everything including a person's fate
however the orville group doesn't pay
much attention to it and simply proceeds
with their mission a while later they
come across a book stall and inquire
about the researchers instead of
answering the owner hands them four
badges mentioning that it is a crime to
walk without one as the four are walking
through the streets lieutenant lamar
tries to have some fun and starts
dancing with a nearby statue commander
kelly immediately tells him to stop but
lamar being lamar continues showcasing
his weird moves just then some people
around them start clicking videos of the
dance and as a result lamar finally gets
down from the statue shortly after the
group reaches a cafe where they notice a
woman being turned down because of her
massive downvote count it turns out that
the people with a large number of
downvotes are shunned by the society of
this world meanwhile the group
approaches a cafe employee lysella and
shows her the picture of the two
researchers that went missing
surprisingly they are told that the two
are popular people as they had been
corrected recently but before they can
interrogate any further all of a sudden
the down votes on lamar's badge start
increasing at an exponential rate the
group is perplexed by what's happening
and just then a tv report displays the
footage of lamar dancing with the statue
strangely the reporter comments that
lamar was humping the statue which turns
out to be a deity on that planet lamar
shall henceforth be referred to as the
god humper confused the group decides to
return back to their planet but when
they reach outside a large mob of people
surround them lamar tries his best to
claim his innocence but sadly a bunch of
officers show up and take him away he is
then brought to prison where a man named
willix who is a publicity officer by
profession approaches him in this world
publicity officers are the equivalent of
lawyers but their jobs are contrastingly
different willix tries to ask lamar his
side of the story but the latter
mentions that he was simply dancing he
also claims to be unaware of all the
rules in the world prompting willix to
tell him everything he mentions that in
sargassu iv everything is democratically
wrong so if a person commits a crime the
public will determine his or her fate by
a voting system if said person reaches
10 million down votes they will be
corrected a correction is a procedure in
which a criminal is electrocuted until
all of their memories are wiped hearing
this lamar becomes terrified and begs
willix to help him but the latter
mentions that there is a legal process
lamar will have to go through a series
of interviews which will be displayed on
live tv and if the audience likes his
apology they might upvote him and save
him hence their best chance to escape
the correction is to prepare a perfect
apology speech travis scott wouldn't
stand a chance on this planet a while
later the orville group visits lamar in
the waiting room and finds out about the
correction that he's going to face
hearing the word correction alara
remembers that the cafe employee lysella
also mentioned that their two friends
had been corrected and that is why they
are so famous in this world hence alara
along with dr clare decides to
interrogate lysella while commander
kelly stays behind with lamar in the
next scene lamar is being readied for
his first apology interview while willix
and claire try their best to motivate
him however the session goes awfully
wrong when lamar makes a mockery out of
himself soon the people start the voting
system and lamar receives a whopping 4
million down votes elsewhere alara and
dr claire approach lysella and start
interrogating her about their missing
colleagues lysella mentions that one was
corrected and sent to a facility while
the other one was shot and killed as he
tried to run away a while later when
alara and claire are in the bathroom
lysella approaches them and accidentally
notices alara's uncovered face scared
she tries running away but the orville
duo calms her down and takes her out for
a drink there alara and claire finally
reveal that they are aliens and that
they have come to take their friends
back soon lysella also starts feeling
comfortable and she tells them that the
researchers were apprehended for not
giving up their seat to a pregnant woman
after this the three head to the
correctional facility and finally find
one of the researchers that was
corrected he appears to be very calm and
has no recollection of what he did
seeing his terrible state dr claire
immediately takes him back to the
orville on the other hand lamar goes to
his second apology interview but once
again things go wrong when he forcefully
high-fives the audience this time the
down vote count reaches 9.3 million back
at the orville everyone is anxious about
lamar as time is running out just then
captain mercer comes up with a plan he
realizes that in order to defeat the
voting system of sargass iv they need an
inside person hence he takes the tough
decision to bring lysella to their base
after she is brought to the orville she
is taken aback to see the facilities and
employees inside it wasting no time
captain mercer conducts a meeting and
asks lysella if there is any way to
change the people's perception towards
lamar the girl thinks for a while and
responds that they might have a chance
if the people get to know the good facts
about lamar hearing this the orville
scientist isaac puts forth a plan to
hack into the voting database and mercer
gives him the heads up elsewhere lamar
is brought to the correction room where
a live vote count is being displayed the
entire population will have 10 minutes
to vote and at the end of the duration
if it reaches 10 million lamar will be
corrected as expected he gets off to the
worst start possible meanwhile at the
orville lysella mentions that the people
on sargassus 4 have sympathy for the
criminals who take care of their
grandmothers have a military record and
love their dogs hearing this isaac uses
his alpha tech skills and hacks into the
voting database he then fabricates the
good facts about lamar and spams it into
the system surprisingly the plan works
and several people start upvoting lamar
with this the votes are equally divided
and lamar is saved a few weeks later the
group again decides to inspect another
planet which resembles medieval earth
this time commander kelly isaac and
lieutenant mallory are tasked with the
mission since the planet consists of
very medieval people the group is
strictly ordered to not come in contact
with anyone as it may result in cultural
contamination shortly after when the
shuttle reaches the planet they notice
that it looks just like earth however it
is several millennia in the past
commander kelly ventures out first and
when she peers through her binoculars
she notices a village nearby after a
while as she is inspecting the place two
little girls suddenly spot her weirded
out by her look they immediately start
running away but one of them trips and
falls causing her head to bleed although
kelly is under strict commands to not
come in contact with anyone on the
planet her maternal instincts can't
simply let the girl bleed out hence she
approaches the little girl and
introduces herself she then takes out
one of her futuristic devices and heals
the girl's wound unfortunately when
kelly turns back she notices that
several medieval people have noticed her
prompting her to run away from the place
later when the entire crew is back to
base to conclude their findings the
mysterious planet vanishes in the blink
of an eye this leaves everyone stunned
but isaac being the smartest guy in the
orville proposes a theory he mentions
that the planet is locked in a
multiphasic orbit such orbits are very
rare because half of it lies in a
universe and the other half in a
separate universe this is why the planet
suddenly disappeared as it has now been
teleported to another universe where it
can complete its orbit finally isaac
concludes by saying that based on the
geometry and mass of the orbit the
planet should return to this universe in
exactly 11 days hearing this captain
mercer and the group decide to wait for
the planet to return in the next scene
isaac's assumption comes to be true as
after 11 days of waiting the planet
finally returns however he senses
something very weird on further
inspection he finds out that although
the planet has returned after 11 days it
has become significantly populated and
advanced and now it resembles 14th
century earth this shocks everyone in
the room and isaac simplifies the
phenomenon in a simple way 11 days may
have passed for the orville but 700
years have passed for the planet this
means that 700 years have passed since
commander kelly and her team visited the
planet astonished by the finding the
team again ventures into the planet and
this time captain mercer also joins them
at first they decide to find some
clothes so that they can blend in with
the people hence they approach a nearby
hut and try stealing some clothes but
just then a lady emerges with her child
she confronts kelly and begs her to
bless her child although confused kelly
hesitantly obliges because of the
incident the group realizes that
something really bad has happened later
when they put on their new clothes and
continue their journey they come across
some corpses hanging on a pole when
captain mercer inquires about them a man
reveals that they were hanged for
spreading blasphemy about their god
kelly that's not all the group also
finds out that the whole village
warships kelly and criminals are
executed in her name even a small kid is
forced to study when his mother mentions
that kelly is watching him stunned the
group reaches a religious temple where
they find an enormous statue of their
god kelly this is when they realized
that kelly's contact with the people 700
years ago changed everything since she
looked modern and healed the girl using
her device rumors spread around the
planet that kelly is a god as a result
they started worshipping her and even
after seven centuries they still regard
her as their savior this is a big
problem for the group as they have
breached a major rule of the orville
hence they try to sort out the problem
before it reaches the higher authorities
after a bit of thinking kelly decides to
confront the head of state volantis and
reveal that she is a mortal shortly
after she reaches a large mansion and
when the guards and volantis recognize
her they immediately drop to their knees
as a sign of respect kelly tells them to
get up and starts explaining that she is
not a god expectedly no one believes her
so kelly cuts her own palm and draws out
some blood she then uses the same device
to heal her wound volantis is baffled by
her healing ability but kelly asserts
that anyone is capable of doing it with
the help of the device she then suggests
volantis do the same and when he cuts
his palm and uses the device it works
this along with the fact that kelly
bleeds like any other being finally
convinces volantis that she is not a god
he then promises to spread the news to
his people claiming that they too should
know the truth after kelly in the group
leaves volantis proceeds to prepare his
men to spread the news throughout the
world however one of his greedy
assistants who believes that kelly is
necessary to mean control over the
people stabs him in the back and kills
him following this the scene fast
forwards by 11 days where the group is
seen waiting for the planet to reappear
soon isaac detects some movements and
the planet which is now transformed into
21st century earth emerges without
wasting any time he conducts some tests
and finds out that the people are still
worshiping kelly however she has also
become controversial as thousands of
people are being killed by terrorists in
her name the group is devastated to
learn that their plan did not work just
when it seems like they are in trouble
kelly comes up with an idea she proposes
that she herself will head to the planet
and stay there her entire life so that
she can prove that she's not a god
however captain mercer immediately
forbids it explaining that this is too
risky just then isaac steps forward and
declares that he'll do it since he's a
robot and knows a great deal about
science the people will believe him
furthermore he will also survive for the
next 700 years as it is only 700 seconds
for him although captain mercer and his
group are still skeptical they decide to
let him go as it is the only way to
repair the damage after this the scene
again skips to 11 days later when the
planet reappears this time it is
transformed into a highly futuristic
world with gigantic cities in it
meanwhile a spaceship approaches the
orville and asks for permission to enter
captain mercer approves of it and two
futuristic-looking aliens along with
isaac enter at first the two thank
captain mercer and the group for sending
isaac as he was one of the driving
forces behind the planet's development
when kelly inquires if she is still
being worshipped the aliens reply that
they stopped doing that a long time ago
however the people are still grateful
that kelly and the other aliens visited
their planet as it gave them the
motivation and willpower to make their
planet similar the episode ends as the
aliens return to their planet while the
orville continues its journey of
exploring to see what happens next watch
the second part in series recap